c'est l'histoire de de Jul et de de Léa
un accident de la route ensemble et
malheureusement léa a subi de de graves
blessures suite à cet accident
puisquelle est elle est paralysée surou
dans un fute roulant les deux ont un peu
abusé de de l'alcool et que c'est Jul
qui conduisait donc joue Jules et donc
on les retrouve quelques temps après
l'accident et on les voit qui essaent de
bah de mener leur vie tant bien que pas
leur vie de de jeunes
adultes mais il se il s'exclue lui-même
il on voit bien au début du courmétrage
il veut pas y aller parce que je pense
qu'il assume pas il veut il veut pas
être confronté au regard des autres et
il veut pas qu'elle se sente inférieure
au malais c'est pour ça qu' il veut
vraiment l'aider à ce qu'elle soit bien
et je pense qu'en voulant faire faire
les choses trop bien pour elle il lui
fait du mal et en voulant enfin voilà
c'est c'est quelqu'un qui vraiment se
rend compte qu'il a fait quelque chose
de mal et il essaie il essaie de se
rattraper mais c'est trop tard
quoi c'est sûr c'est carrément à
l'opposé de de ce que je fais sur scène
donc j'aime de jouer la comédie en tant
comédien c'est c'est un truc nouveau et
que j'aime beaucoup aprè voilà s'il y a
du fond c'est ce qu'on cherche tous un
rôle qui du fond c'est il y a rien de
mieux et là on peut pas trouver ave ça
quoi moi j'ai euu des films qui m'ont
qui m'ont donné envie de faire plein de
chos j'ai vu des films au cinéma qui
m'ont donné envie d'être papa j'ai vu
des des films qui m'ont donné envie
d'être amoureux j'ai vu des films qui
m'ont fait prendre mon téléphone et
appeler mon père et dire bah papa voilà
je te dis je te le dis pas assez bah
merci d'être là encore une fois c'est un
formidable outil pour pour faire passer
les
messages parce que j'ai j'ai juste adoré
tous ces films
c'est ma vie en mère c'est le seul film
que j'ai vu trois fois au cinéma et
c'est quelqu'un c'est un vrai c'est un
ré très moderne et je trouve très fin
dans dans sa façon de montrer les
relations entre les gens à faire passer
des émotions dans tous ces films j'ai vu
des des truc mais énormément touchant et
nonous on dit comme ça puis quelqu'un on
voit qui est très pudi qui est très très
calme très Z il est pas enfin il le fait
vraiment sincèrement ça sent que c'est
quelqu'un qui qui a vraiment un très
très bon fond fait bateau de dire ça sur
de ciné mais mais on sent que il est
profondément humain et je trouve que
c'est bien encore une fois il correspond
bien avec ce projet parce qu'il il fait
passer des émotion sans en rajouter en
fait B voilà